here funny you don't look Middle Eastern
all right so I figured since she's here
he's our guest for a minute
[Music]
trailer I wanted to gift him with this
book it's something that hopefully could
be a treasure for him if he takes time
to check it out
in the Mysteries misconceptions revolve
around it thank you now you go to the
source have you ever heard of this book
no it says Korean yes okay so hope you
enjoy it
will yeah give me some understanding of
what's going on
honey you don't look Middle Eastern like
in the Lord's Prayer
we understand
the fake news we understand all of that
garbage out there but now you have a
fringe element just like you know in any
religion that might do some things
militant yes and then what happens the
media capitalize you know hate
provocateurs they try to spread fears
yeah yeah yeah but a Muslim one who
submits his will to God can be an Arab
which is which is uh 10 12 of the home
Muslim population can be Italian can be
Bosnian can be you know from any country
yeah you know any any place that's it
all right yeah and there's a whole
chapter in this book named after Jesus's
mother it's called Miriam man yeah it's
an article of faith in Islam to believe
and love Jesus I appreciate it I'm
curious to see what it says yes thank
you very much and it's not a coincidence
I don't think anything's by chance I
think you were here just at the right
time I come in and we meet and yeah
all right God bless you we've been told
that uh they're out to kill us all Salam
Lincoln brothers and sisters we went to
the streets to ask Americans about Islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no I'm sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all right that's
what you've been told that Muslims are
out to kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're going to have four
wives brothers and sisters as you can
see there are so many Americans who
don't know about Islam we need your help
to change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign